the draft is pretty much the opposite of
last year bodyline huh sorry is good
idea Gary
Bobby lion first champion of the super
league the trophy is called the Glennon
Cup but I think we want over this area
so this one have to slide down so we
need to get rid of this I think so yeah
or push it back up against the wall
yes is gonna work for the last 20 years
has been one of my favorite days of the
year keep working what for it last year
how bad was it the poor thing
I was real at the NFL you know McGowan's
not here anymore
the Kris Bryant's of the world and those
things it helps people be in it every
two or three years instead of what this
if you push it too far down you're
taking the value out of those
unbelievable minor leaguer that's out of
the equation so that's me Interpol start
really weird Bumgardner
ten bucks fifteen twenty so I think it's
doing the best so far I'm really not
paying attention to what any individuals
do it I'm only working on my we can't
predict pitching so we're just gonna get
his bunch of as many Japanese pictures
as we can yeah okay seven like they are
the least predictable of the picture
basically if you're gonna roll the dice
you should have someone else draft sorry
a little bit slow people were a little
gun-shy and some of the big bats coming
out I think they've opened up their
their purses a little bit dialed 22
going twice
there's still a lot of deals happening
you just have to be patient this is
where like the cream resident top a lot
people get anxious people miss out on
some of the bargains that open happening
now there's a lot people aren't sure who
to spend their like what's a little left
of their treasury I'm on Hillman twice
hold and the 24 who is 24 doing good do
you're at focus is gonna be on it's
gonna be on pitching compete you think
so I think well I think we're a year
ahead of that I think 2018 will be there
this is where you have to kind of make
some some take some risks on some
mid-level guys that could hopefully pop
into a high level guys we'll see what
happens to the people who really did
their homework gonna show up in and then
that like next two hours that's my
opinion
feeling good other than James Shields
that was a mistake I know James Shields
oh I'll go for $5 Wow I'll go for
7-eleven well 13 and got you lucuma beat
up for it a little bit so now I need
some power I need some steals exactly
that's it that's it
also the Astra's I think the next two
hours is really going to find the draft
though yeah I'm gonna be super laid back
just working on email it's gonna be you
know making a couple plays here and
there yeah we're probably the 14th most
prepared team in the league but I think
that we're performing like the 6th best
prepared team exactly end of the day not
not the best not the best but you know
we're building for next year so I've got
a long season ahead of us you know we're
in an interesting position kind of
rebuilding a team we inherited I got a
kind of Rhea Regis strategy rejigger
rejigger some things yeah we also have
very arbitrary rules for our team so
like no one gets the green light we're
not it's it's a ding dong or you riding
the pine right Dan Rock it's kind of how
we roll in life in general I'd say but
you know a little under prepared always
overperform so I look at it so the whole
thing aging Gary's in Bucks so we're in
tune with their strategies current
assistant former assistants so we pretty
much see everything and so we got a role
and we got to be good we got some inside
info that it thinks gonna really show
itself in cleaning up the conference
members
tyler brought a lot of heat to the table
cause a lot of super dominant
I'm gonna put in a day and then so I
mean I feel pretty good I wish my you
know the entry fee was waived as well
now I feel like that's wait am i a point
nine dollars sold generic man I wanted
seriously I wanna go bad
it's gonna be huge here huge so I said
laughter we'll see that's a little
boombox that Yankee Stadium you two
let's go dominated I've done everything
right I've gotten every player I've
wanted maybe the maybe the Tyson Ross
instead of smiley but I have them very
similar if some Ross a little bit better
and I paid a little bit more for smiley
but other net it's been a perfect draft
I'm perfect quite perfect smiley
overpaid two really good values I'm
pitching that's it but I want it's
finally got a win now Godwin in the next
two hours you're right
gotta win in the next two hours it's
been a long time since I drafted a guy I
kind of forgot how that works but I'm
thinking I've got enough money to get
who I want the rest of the way and still
plenty of guys I'm looking for but yeah
I'm dropped in about a guy an hour so I
might keep everyone here pretty late
we'll see how it goes
so Brandon Jeff to work tomorrow
cuz I still need like I do have to work
so we got seven and a quarter rounds of
drafting you go okay seven and a quarter
yes
where's the quarter come from I had to
set 140 players when that just be seven
your metrics are almost done that'll
kill me
just seven so I filled up my pitching
staff first which is kind of interesting
although I came in with five pictures so
it's not too shocking my big strategy
was to get one of the top four or five
starting pitchers I got Madison
Bumgarner who happened to be the first
guy thrown at budget at 46 I got 45 so
that part worked out I bought three
closers now which I do think is a good
commodity in this league and then you
know we're gonna have to see how it goes
in the end game filling out my offense I
think I might have a few holes I'm
really pumped another good owner if we
can really do it we'll sell it to the
second place oh yeah oh I'd love to see
someone take trout from us and lose
heartbreaking right like I don't want to
contribute to someone else's happiness
right the goal of our team really yeah
just to really make the league like all
right we'll play spoiler this year
absolutely yeah kind of wrestling
villains if we're not doing a good job
of it in the season we will literally
spoil your food yeah become a savage in
office good man don't win at all costs
so yeah day's going pretty well I guess
catch oh yeah we get rid of deer oh and
big Lou yeah I'd like for Gary to stop
telling me I'm gonna get kicked out next
year that'd be great that'd be swell
yeah good times
graphic Kershaw $64 Oh Sam I'm fine
going in other than that I'm just trying
to pick out value I feel good I mean
couldn't really compete this year I blew
all my assets last year but I just want
some good guys see how it goes life is
whatever 19
going twice
hoes have never actually been on a whole
lotta Matt put the camera on him so we
could put that fun actually I think
there's a couple things I would change
but I think I got a decent players
second suppliers your name mmm-hmm oh
yeah oh really huh okay Tom uh Tom had
to he has to be a good person I know you
have to go bring bring a new child into
the world my impression was that I was
not allowed to have a partner [ __ ] you I
only have $1 players left
I think I'm clearly having the best
draft have a good chance to be the first
repeat winner in the league
Brian bronze the steel the draft and
feeling really good a lot of money left
on the table but I'm not worried about
it I think a good draft well nothing I
regret good no regret are a gr 80s
Harold asleep okay about true beating
if I win this little quick that's my
declaration for dailyvee can you get
that on camera enough ones are the best
I didn't prepare enough for lately draft
but fell apart a little bit I talked too
much trash when I made that one video
with you it felt really good it didn't
go as well as I thought double stretch
it cost me been traveling too much too
much Ireland too much Australia feeling
good do your act we got out we got the
fourth overall we got the fourth overall
pick here then we're picking again at 15
so I think we're gonna get a couple a
couple nice a couple nice assets here
that'll have us they don't have us ready
to contend in a couple of years yeah a
couple a couple couple quality guys on
the board just have to hope have a top 3
after hope one slips too many and will
will adjust their feel pretty good feel
pretty good it was the grip draft didn't
go exactly the way I expected it to but
you know I think I have to spend a
little time looking over how the whole
thing went for everybody but I like the
guys that I ended up with and some of
the end game now I got some power got
some speed I got some average guys it's
a big balance feel better on to this
these minors pics are done Rory your way
we're tears away where year and a half
away so we need these guys we need them
all righty
once that's one to be grow I think I I
made the moves I need to make I'm like
two years away from a championship so
it's gonna be a lot of a lot of a lot of
bad starts this year a lot of bad stats
I'm gonna figure it out and you know I
feel like there's a Sonny 2017 you know
I feel like I was shut out in the end a
little bit I feel like there's a lot of
players that the league was denying me
and hold it against something and after
I take first place three years in a row
starting this year I think I think the
Lee's gonna really regret the way the
Patriots my team when you have Kris
Bryant cause Korea it's very unlike with
an extra titles and so that's usually
get sad when it ends but now that we go
to dinner together makes me happy
so mashed uh the vaynermedia MyLibrary
people together in one big league a lot
of fun it's a good day great day
I'm here because someone actually needs
to do work around here can I say it
without you sorry kid I'm here because
someone actually needs to do work around
here and when you walk in
yeah this three huh a little bit it's
quite official shocking you know hell
yeah white Friday don't know what's
going on about half of it yeah yeah
probably about half way by then they're
talking about players of the baseball
game mm-hmm this was good